frantz thodiard le président du
directoire de l'entreprise société
aéroport martinique aimé césaire la
somme mac est avec nos bonjour monsieur
tout dire bonjour aux sultans face aux
dires l'aéroport c'est un vaste chantier
est vaste chantier car la structure
droit se moderniser et s'apprêtait à
faire face à de nouveaux challenges
aurait dit on va dire ça comme ça
absolument c'est une structure qui doit
s'adapter
j'allais dire à la fois l'évolution dont
de l'activité du transport aérien et qui
doit s'adapter à une stratégie de
développement du territoire donc dicté
par nos élus ce qui donne donc je vais
dire le cap et en particulier notre
conseil d'administration
parce que nos actionnaires j'allais dire
parce que la savak est une société donc
de droit privé
un conseil de surveillance avec des
actionnaires que sont l'état la chambre
de commerce d'industrie de la martinique
la collectivité territoriales de la
martinique
la ville du lamentin et la ville de
ducos document les actionnaires et qui
nous donne des orientations en matière
de développement et la matière de
stratégie et c'est quoi la stratégie
numéro un c'est faire plus de trafic
alors la stratégie numéro un c'est de de
développer l'entreprise parce que nous
sommes d'avoir une entreprise et
développer l'entreprise s'élevait à sa
performance économique et aussi nous
sommes un outil au service du
développement économique et
singulièrement du développement
touristique de l'île fait du pays
martinique
donc c'est d'offrir à la martinique un
outil au service de son développement et
en particulier du transport aérien
donc nous nous devons de nous adapter à
l'évolution j'ai à dire de la
fréquentation de la martinique a tout de
tout type de matière touristique de
nature des échanges familiaux de la thur
des échanges de business des affaires
donc on doit s'adapter à toute évolution
du transport aérien et donc aussi à vis
de développement économiques de la
matinée c'est pour ça donc il ya ce
projet d'extension de l'aéroport
plusieurs millions de travaux autour
d'une centaine dont le financement a été
chose facile
rien n'est facile vous savez donc
quand on a conçue justement donc le
projet de développement et l'extension
de l'aérogare et de modernisation des
installations de l'aéroport
c'est pour servir donc un développement
comme je les dis donc c'est un projet de
l'autre 224 millions d'euros
il a fallu aller convaincre allez
convaincre les partenaires financiers
que sont d'abord d'impoli tard parce que
nous répondons à aux grandes
orientations stratégiques donc qu'ils
soient arrêtés par nos actionnaires en
l'occurrence l'élite à la collectivité
la chambre de commerce la ville de la
montée en habit de ducos donc nous avons
arrêté ses grandes orientations
stratégiques de développement de
l'aéroport d'extension de l'aérogare de
modernisation des installations par le
centre d'affaires j'y reviendrai parce
que c'est un autre projet c'est un autre
projet qui concourent à l'offre
l'attractivité de la destination
mais pour les points à voter à votre
question est très précisément le
développement de l'aéroport est un
projet de 124 millions d'euros
il a fallu donc à les convaincre donc
les partenaires financiers que sont
l'état je les dis l'europe la
collectivité était pitoyable mais à un
peu avancé à la région lorsque nous
avons commencé de la région donc avant
2015 pour convaincre la région et puis
vérifier que l'entreprise a les moyens
de sa politique c'est à dire que la part
d'autofinancement que keane ou
résultaient donc de ce plan de
financement
nous étions capables de le faire et
d'aller convaincre des banques des
partenaires financiers pour pouvoir nous
accompagnent et donc aujourd'hui c'est
fait on assiste aux premiers coups de
pioche alors avec avec des sociétés qui
sont capables d'aller jusqu'au bout j'ai
cru comprendre qu'ils sont la société et
qui s'est vu attribuer le marché
connaîtra quelques difficultés dites
nous tout ce matin alors si c'est 1
c'est un groupement d'entreprises dont
le chef de file est effectivement donc
in so puisque le type de marché que nous
avons conclus donc avec ce groupement
c'est un groupement est un marché de
conception-réalisation comme vous êtes
un conception donc vous avez d'abord à
faire donc à un architecte est le
cabinet d'architectes nord qui a qui
fait partie du groupement et qu'il
aurait ya donc de la compétition que
nous avons lancé donc maintenant deux
ans et un cabinet nantais que le cabinet
alia
qui intervient d'ailleurs sur l'aéroport
de north d'ailleurs qui intervient sous
l'ère au cours de la réunion
et c'est au cabinet dentaire donc avec
un projet on a acheté se voulait donc un
objet architectural
on a acheté donc des fonctionnalités et
puis vous avez à la tête d'un groupement
d'entreprises une entreprise
effectivement italienne d'ailleurs quand
une entreprise qui a c'est l'entreprise
qui a construit là où nous sommes
à savoir donc le complexe de la tour
lumineux donc c'est une entreprise qui
aujourd'hui comme toute entreprise
connaît des hauts et des bas donc
monsieur yves ça de très près chaque
jour suffit sa peine et a pas
d'inquiétude pour les saumons je vous
parle j'ai pas d'âge et pas d'inquiétude
je ne sais pas ce qu'il en sera demain
d'accord alors ça c'est pour la
structure très rapidement il y aura un
centre d'affaires il y aura nos têtes
rapidement parce qu'on prépare les 2 du
trafic passager absolument donc qui a le
projet qui est le projet d'extension et
de modernisation de l'aéroport
je rappelle qui passe par l'extension du
nombre de postes de stationnement avions
que nous avons construit deux fois
socialement avions gros-porteurs
supplémentaires on a modernisé notre
centrale de production de froid on a
modernisé notre centrale de ce qu
électrique et puis donc ça c'est
l'aérogare et construit vingt mille
mètres carrés de surface de plancher par
rapport au 24 mai il existe un quasiment
doublement et nous avons effectivement
un complément un centre d'affaires avec
des bureaux à louer avec un centre de
séminaires et un hôtel d'environ 120
chambres que nous avons donc que nous
sommes en train de finaliser et nous
l'espérons qui va voir le jour assez
rapidement alors ça c'est pour la
structure et les réseaux mis sur pied
pour faire venir du monde on va revenir
forcément sur la norvégienne qui est
parti définitivement c'est fini le
dossier est clos
pas du tout on peut relancer ce n'est
pas du tout pas du tout donc la
norvégienne comme beaucoup d'autres
j'allais dire source de développement de
2 du trafic aérien en martinique fait
partie de l'ensemble nous avons une
stratégie que nous que nous avons
décliné qui s'appelle donc qui dit
ouvrir le ciel de la martinique au monde
ce n'est pas une posture
c'est vraiment une vraie stratégie c'est
à dire de permettre aux martiniquais
d'aller où il veut quand il veut et
surtout de faire venir le plus possible
de touristes et de visiteurs chez nous
pour tout le temps les forces des
sergents table mais pardon il n'y a pas
que la norvégienne si vous voulez la
norvégienne s'est je rappelle que le
trafic de l'aéroport martinique aimé
césaire c'est quasiment 2 millions de
passagers en 2010
suite la norvégienne fait soixante mille
passagers ouais donc vous voyez le
rapport qu'on subventionne la rotation
n'est pas du tout notre avenir ne dépend
pas de la norvégienne nous avons plein
de développement et plein de contacts
avec d'autres d'autres compagnies alors
c'est vrai que quand on est on est on
est très con était très content donc on
souhaite pas que la norvégienne par et
donc nous faisons tout pour que la
norvégienne rectifie corrige sa position
et nous sommes entrés avec le comité
martiniquais du tourisme et la
collectivité territoriale de faire en
sorte de leur demander de corriger en
fait de revenir sur leur position et
nous sommes en discussion avec eux alors
les chiffres les chiffres de ce passager
qui viennent en martinique il existe
mais pourquoi les gardes et très jalouse
manger cru comprendre n'y a pas si
longtemps que les professionnels du
tourisme notamment ceux de l'hôtellerie
vous accusent de les garder jalousement
que voulait pas partager on ne sait même
pas pourquoi pas du tout alors la taz
entendu il s'agit ciel dit s'agissant de
la cemac
moi je peux vous dire que ma position
moi les couleurs de des empennage
d'avion les queue d'avion
personnellement c'est pas mon problème
l'essentiel c'est que nous puissions
offrir aux martiniquais la possibilité
de là où il d'aller là où ils veulent
quand ils veulent et de faire venir des
visiteurs de tous les pays possibles en
fonction des doigts ce trafic c'est un
vrai sujet et ce qu'il faut à conserver
la couleur de la queue de l'avion dont
l'empennage de l'avion ça ne m'intéresse
pas je veux dire que toutes les
compagnies qui sont aujourd'hui qui
existent si elles peuvent faire du
développement
je suis ouvert à tout la norvégienne a
joué le jeu avec nous après pratiquement
deux ans de discussions avec eux de
venir chez nous bon ils ont aujourd'hui
annoncé leur volonté de pouvoir partir
parce que globalement la norvégienne à
plein des difficultés de partout sur
toutes les bases mais je peux vous dire
que nous sommes aussi en contact avec
d'autres compagnies qui sont aussi
intéressés par des marchés pas ce qui
est important ce sont les marchés qui
ont été défrichés et qui existaient qui
aujourd'hui existe aujourd'hui on a un
potentiel des changes entre la
martinique et new york la martinique il
faut leur dire la martinique et la
martinique la haie et montréal comme
d'autres destinations que nous
souhaitons ouvrir l'argentine le brésil
jadis est ouvert à toutes les compagnies
d'accord derniers chiffres terre des
chiffres à propos des taxes alors la
compagne aérienne disent que finalement
leurs biens sont pas si cher que ça ce
sont les taxes aéroportuaires qui qui
qui qui plombe le prix du billet d'avion
très rapidement en quelques secondes
vous répondez quoi en quelques secondes
je réponds que il faut vraiment
connaître la structure des prix du
billet d'avion quand vous prenez moi
jeune exemple sous les yeux que vous
prenez un billet pour aller à paris
la redevance de l'aéroport martinique
aimé césaire qui consiste à faire payer
le passager pour l'utilisation des
installations de l'aéroport tu sais - 2
4 % du prix du billet - 2 4 % du prix du
billet à côté de la redevance passager
que nous faisons payer
vous avez des redevances de l'aviation
civile vous avez des redevances donc
pour les pays en voie de développement
la fameuse taxe chirac
vous avez la taxe passager qui est payé
pour financer les investissements et le
fonctionnement matière de sûreté de
sécurité et ce à l'aéroport pet les
investissements et récupère la taxe des
fois avec un différé et nous perdons de
l'argent en termes de trésorerie
donc le poids de la redevance qui
revient la halle haas hamac dans le prix
de composition de billets soit un billet
paris c'est -4% dernière question fera
la dernière question prêter du doigt
montré du doigt la qualité des
sanitaires à l'aéroport c'est un gros
problème pour vous c'est un vrai sujet
c'est un vrai sujet nous leur
connaissons ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
que ça fait deux ans que nous avons
lancé des appels d'offres pour la
réfection des toilettes et nous
n'arrivons pas à trouver une entreprise
non pas techniquement capables une
entreprise en règle avec ses obligations
fiscales et sociales pour travailler
avec nous nous ne pouvons pas travailler
avec une autre pays qu'ils soient pas en
règle avec ses obligations fiscales et
sociales
voilà merci france honneur d'avoir été
ce peintre est avec nous on rappelle que
vous êtes le président du directoire de
l'entreprise samak merci bonne journée
merci monsieur le tout